[Music]
my body is my temple that's why I start
every morning with a Brisk aerobic
workout but I can't do it alone workouts
are easier when you have a partner my
workout partner is my maid margarite
margarit soft brown stomach protects my
knees and ankles from unnecessary wear
and tear not too much longer me SOA
okay that mean shut up in
Spanish 15 minutes a day is all you need
to get your heart rate up to please miss
SOA you're crushing
my Sorry Miss
sopra for those of you on the audio only
podcast that was old Comedy Central
video of Jimmy Kimmel in blackace in a
fat suit pretending to be a woman
stamping on a Latina immigrant uh I'm
Dave Ruben this is the Ruben report it's
January 4th
2024 uh we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share subscribe tap
that notification Bell if you haven't
postgame show Ruben report. locals.com
immediately after the show and there is
a reason we are showing you Jimmy Kimmel
black face in a fat suit as a woman
jumping up and down on a Latina
immigrant it's because he's in a bit of
a feud right now with Aaron roders and
you might go well Dave who cares about a
feud between you know kind of like I I
can't say he's washed up right like the
guy's a late night TV host probably
making 30 m years so let's not say
washed up but hacky late night comedian
who's just part of the Machine versus
Aaron roders Aaron Rogers obviously
football legendary uh quarterback now on
the Jets they've gotten into a feud over
the and this brings it to what we're
talking about today uh these Jeffrey
Epstein uh files that have been unsealed
and they've been fighting uh yesterday
and now today not a good two days for
Bill Clinton and a whole bunch of other
people including Stephen Hawking Stephen
Hawking what what at an orgy what what
no pictures were released thankfully um
anyway we're going to cover all of that
and then we've got a Ruben report
Community Q&A so actually if you want to
try to get a question in on the Fly you
can jump over to Ruben report.
locals.com right now and we'll see if we
can add something as we're doing this
live so okay so I want to take you back
a little bit oh and I should say before
you know I haven't done much on this
Epstein stuff I I honestly don't know
what to make of it it kind of feels like
the whole thing was a Honey Trap
basically you know where where
intelligence agencies kind of just get
people to be at things offer them these
young girls and then you can kind of
blackmail people like that's what
generally people think of that kind of
seems right to me they released these
docs yesterday what a lot of people are
saying is that they've already redacted
all of the important names so the names
that they're releasing now are just like
oh these are people we can just kind of
throw to the Wolves that's what's so
interesting about Bill Clinton because
he's a former president and it seems
like he's sort of a sacrificial lamb
here now of course if he banged underage
girls or God knows what he did then you
got to pay the price but it seems like
he's being thrown out of the thrown off
the bus or under the bus while some
other people are probably going to get
away so let's go back now for a moment
uh a couple days ago on the Pat McAfee
show on ESN he had Aaron roders on uh
and they knew that these Epstein files
were about to be released and Aaron
Rogers has been going at it with Jimmy
Kimmel for a while mostly over covid
stuff uh but then Aaron Rogers had this
to say about Jimmy and the Epstein
files bring it up bring it up foxy or
somebody back there on it Super Bowl 58
you'll see it the emblem put on the
screen and then bring up 57 and 56 this
has something to do with the Epstein
list that came out feels feels that's
supposed to be coming out soon that's
supposed to be coming out soon look this
guy's been waiting in his wine seller
I've been waiting in my wine seller for
this a lot of people including Jimmy
Kimmel are really hoping that
doesn't all right all right obviously a
clip from this particular program was
run on Jimmy Kimmel show uh whenever
Aaron brought up the the list and then
Jimmy mocked him for it Aaron has not
forgotten about that but here we are
sitting right in front of that nice
bottle of Scotch what do you say I'm
waiting to celebrate something oh yeah
he's been waiting for you been waiting
for I'll tell you what if that list
comes out I definitely will be popping
popping some sort of bottle hey you've
been called for it for a few years now
anyone else noticed this oh my god oh
yeah oh wow yeah yeah they've known
that's they known for years like I'm
saying that next at 59 better be jet
Green that's all I'm saying interesting
yeah well unless it's Colts blue
remember we got Anthony Richardson
coming the Patriots blue might be there
too okay sorry we should have cut a
little bit earlier there you got a
little inside football uh Super Bowl
stuff there uh the point of all of this
because you might be going Dave why why
does this matter how's this really
related to the EPS thing is that Kimmel
and uh Aaron Rogers have been fighting
over covid for a long time so Kimmel's
done a million jokes and gone after him
on Twitter and everything else because
Aaron Rogers did not want to get vaxed
and there seems to be this odd
connection between all of these people
who were say skeptical of the vaccine
and the mainstream people always trying
to take them out calling them rightwing
dingbats I believe that's exactly what
he called him if I'm not mistaken and
now apparently Aaron Rogers very happy
that Jimmy Kimmel supposedly was going
to be on the list now as far as I've
seen up until the moment we started the
show Jimmy Kimmel was actually not on
the release list as I said there's
probably a whole bunch of redacted stuff
and people that are just not on there
that will maybe never know
about what Aaron Rogers was also
connecting this to is here is video of
Jimmy Kimmel and apparently his best
friend and Chef Adam Perry Lang who also
was Jeffrey Epstein's personal chef for
years a little bizarre but take a look
where they cook the food that the hot
side and then theold side the APL stands
for Adam Perry Ling the restaurant's
owner and Chef and Jimmy's longtime
friend how did you guys meet we don't
even know each other no well this is
awkward we met Adam was a chef on my
show he barbecued a whole pig a whole
pig in our parking lot and the rest is
La foodie history okay so I have no idea
what's going on here exactly other than
Jimmy Kimmel is now being very defensive
Jimmy Kimmel who calls everyone
right-wing maniacs and you know January
six insurrectionists and and racists
while he's in blackface and all of that
stuff uh he is not very happy right now
that Aaron Rogers is going after him
right he said that if you didn't get the
VX you were going to kill everybody and
that hospitals shouldn't take care of
you we've played some of those quote
unquote jokes uh before anyway here's a
tweet from Jimmy Kimmel about Aaron
Rogers he wrote dear for the
record I've not met flown with visited
or had any contact whatsoever with
Epstein nor will you find my name on any
other on any list other than the clearly
phony nonsense that soft brain wackos
like yourself can't seem to distinguish
from reality your Reckless words put my
family in danger keep it up and we will
debate the facts further in court so
that that's really why I wanted to do
this because who knows what's exactly
true here but there's a certain set of
people that sling mud at everybody right
the vax the unvaxxed shouldn't get uh
help at hospitals these people are all
racists and white supremacists and
everything else and then when they get
attacked then we're going to talk about
uh who's going to go to court and
everything else but putting all of that
drama aside for just a moment that was
really our way of just getting into this
there are some pretty notable people uh
who are being hit in this Epstein list
uh Bill Clinton is the main one here is
a picture of Bill Clinton this is not a
new picture this is a picture of Bill
Clinton and Jeffrey Epstein from this is
probably about 30 or so years ago uh and
here is an image this is a picture of a
painting that was hanging in Jeffrey
Epstein's townhouse in New York City
that's Bill Clinton obviously in a Blue
Dress which is a reference to Monica
Lewinsky uh that he's pointing like
there's just something kind of fishy and
weird about this okay so be it uh here's
video this is uh this is what about two
three weeks ago Bill Clinton being asked
about his friendship with Jeffrey
Epstein it's a little hard to hear the
audio here but hopefully you'll get it
any comments on the alleged allegation
of your connection with Jeffrey
[Music]
mste all right he kind of does what they
all do like he laughs it off and then he
says saying I think the evidence is it's
unclear what he says I think the
evidence is clear I think the evidence
is unclear I don't know exactly but when
it comes to evidence so yesterday this
list was released and Bill Clinton was
in it take a look this is from the
deposition that they released uh
question let me back up do you know if
Bill Clinton was a friend of Jeffrey
Epstein answer I knew he had dealings
with Bill Clinton I did not know they
were friends until I read the Vanity
Fair article about them going to Africa
together question did Jeffrey ever talk
to you about Bill Clinton answer he said
one time that Clinton likes them young
referring to girls now I believe the
person being questioned in that is one
of at the time one of the underaged
girls who knows if she's telling the
truth or anything else but this is now
evidence right like when people are
testifying under oath this is evidence
so Bill Clinton was asking for evidence
to be released well it's a type of
evidence right there uh there is a
little bit more it gets weirder uh this
is an email from Jeffrey Epstein to
Jazelle Maxwell who is now the only
person in prison related to any of these
files so this is Epstein to Maxwell you
can issue a reward to any of Virginia's
friends acquaintances now Virginia is
one of the underage girls uh Virginia's
friends acquaintances family that come
forward and help prove her allegations
are false the strongest is the Clinton
dinner and the new version in the Virgin
Islands uh that th Hawking participated
in an underage
orgy what are we doing with our lives
what are we doing you know what I mean
there's got to be more important things
happening isn't there an invasion on the
southern border stepen Hawking is in an
orgy Bill Clinton like what is happening
here anyway here's how the New York
Times is covering it if you just want to
see how absolutely evil the mainstream
media is hundreds of pages of previously
sealed court documents related to
Jeffrey Epstein the disgraced Finance
year and registered sex offender were
made public Wednesday but are but as
most legal experts familiar with the
affair surmised there was no smoking gun
list there's testified uh there's
testimony in a deposition that Bill
Clinton likes them young and an orgy
involving
like step Hawking like
I let's just show you one more this is
from Vice I mean This Is How They Run
cover for people the Jeffrey Epstein
story is Fanning Flames Fanning the
Flames of far-right pedophilia
Panic uh like some of this kind of
sounds like it probably was true anyway
just a little bit more to wrap this to
where we started at the top with Aaron
Rogers and Jimmy Kimmel uh Kimmel had
been attacking Aaron Rogers for years uh
calling him a dingbat and an antivaxer
and he didn't want to get the covid VX
and everything else so here is Aaron
Rogers on Joe Rogan this is a couple
months back on what it was like to be
attacked for being a conspiracy theorist
who wouldn't get vaxed science that
can't be questioned isn't isn't science
anymore it's propaganda right and that
was my problem with the whole thing
is science is propagated by peer review
yes and you have an idea and then giving
it to your colleagues or a study group
or an institution and then having them
review it yes and figure out did you
make any sense or there's some
holes in it yeah right but there wasn't
any questioning of the information that
was put out well was it was it wasn't
allowed there was questioning but it
wasn't allowed you're automatically put
into antivaxer flatter Earth crazy white
right-wing
conspiracy right like we all get it
anyone that questioned the vaccines
questioned the mandates if you question
anything related to diversity equity and
inclusion all of these things they label
you these things the machine then puts
out comedians late night hosts they put
out television uh journalists quote
unquote journalists out there to label
everybody all of these awful things and
it just marches on so I think I don't
know I just think there was something
interesting about this Kimmel Aaron
Rogers thing as it relates to the
Epstein list how is Bill Clinton sort of
the one really big name that seems to be
getting crushed in this thing and we're
not going to find out about a whole
bunch of other people like did they
clean up the list over the last five
years why did the list just come out
yesterday there's a whole bunch there I
don't know that I have any more insight
into it than any of you do I think
there's more questions than answers
right now and speaking of questions and
answers we're about to get to a Ruben
report. locals.com Community Q&A but let
me talk to you guys about ramp real
quick guys running a business is tricky
and you have to stay on top of every
little detail across expenses payments
and accounting who can you use to make
or break what who you use can make or
break you and you need the best ramp is
a complete GameChanger and saves you
time from getting trapped in busy work
while maximizing productivity and
cutting wasteful spending ramp is a
corporate card and spend management
software designed to help you save time
and put money back in your pocket in
fact businesses that use ramp save and
average of 5% in the first year with
ramp you're able to issue cards to every
employee with limits and restrictions
and automate expense reporting so you
can stop wasting time at the end of
every month they're also easy to use
issue virtual and physical cards and
start making payments in less than 15
minutes whether you have five employees
or 5,000 ramp will save you time and
money get $250 when you join ramp today
just go to ramp.com rubben ramp.com
r.com Rubin cards issued by Sutton Bank
and Celtic Bank members FDI I see terms
and conditions apply and now back to
me actually if we take any questions on
the fly if you guys have any other
insight into what the hell's going on
with this least this list the timing of
it and everything else I'm I'm really
all ears on this one Sarah says do you
think that these crazy lefties in the
media actually believe they are doing
good for this country or are they just
putting on a front it is very hard to
say I think it's a combination of
everything first off the road to hell is
paav with good intentions right so I
think most people most people in general
think they're doing good right like most
people don't wake up in the morning
think they're thinking they're going to
put evil out into the world bad people
even people that do horrible things
Hitler in his own mind I have no doubt
thought he was doing good so your
intentions are sort of irrelevant it's
what the results of your work your
thoughts your Deeds actually bring to
fruition in the world that's actually
what matters I would say a lot of of
these people are are just really really
Bamboozled like if you were to look at
say like the women of the view like I
think they're just really Bamboozled
Whoopi Joy these were like sane funny
interesting actors comic people that
weren't like crazy Lefty activists and
then we just watched we watched the left
go bananas and they were just on the
ride right then you've got somebody like
Sunny host I I actually think she's a
genuine racist and not particularly
bright and the way she lies or the way
that Anna Navaro who lives here in
Florida and flourishes here in Florida
and she drives around her Maserati
married to her husband who's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars and
pretends that this is some awful place
like you she's genuinely bad I would say
someone like Alysa Farah it's like
you're there because they put you in the
chair to be the pet Republican to get
tapped on the head every now and again
so you don't sound crazy all the time
but you know you'll never sort of
accomplish your cause you'll just take
money for it um I I don't know no like
ultimately like it's it's probably on
each individual person to be judged
really um but I do think most of them
think most of them do think they are
doing good uh Shelly says Dave I just
finished listening to today's people of
the internet and would like to know what
product you use in your hair that comes
from Italy that keeps your hair quite
Dapper looking especially with the
humidity in Florida that might be the
icing on the cake for me to relocate to
the free state of Florida if I didn't
have to worry about my hair getting
frizzy all the time
this has become an issue in my family
because my parents do live part-time in
Florida I'm trying to get them down here
more often and my mom's always worried
that the humidity is going to you know
kind of push the hair down a little bit
more uh I think we have a picture of my
product I took it this morning in the
bathroom that's right I found this
product I don't know that you can get
this in stores I think we have it's
called organ organ organic pure care I
found this at a resort in Mexico like
two years ago because I forgot my gel
when we were traveling I forgot my hair
product bought it at the resort
absolutely love it Daphne is in touch
with people over there and she gets it
directly to me and if you can get a hold
of it I mean you know it's going to keep
the hair going even in even in the
humidity we welcome you to the free
state of Florida Nara says did you David
and the boys have a wonderful time
sharing the holidays with family and
friends knowing how much you enjoy music
did you play special songs from your
private playlist for all of them I think
it would be terrific if you could share
just three of those songs with us your
Ruben night Family Music lifts spirits
and makes you smile you know I believe
that I have shared the official I have
the Dave ruin party Perfection playlist
it's about seven and a half hours of the
perfect party playlist that's what we
played for the big Ruben report holiday
party people love this playlist Brock do
you love this playlist every song that
came on Brock said my God this is the
best song I've ever heard that's how
good this playlist is okay I'll post the
link to that one in Loc
uh yeah we have music playing throughout
the house all day long I you know lately
believe it this is going to sound corny
but I have been loving it I am loving
musac lately you guys know what mu
before your time you guys don't even
know what musac is musac muu z a was
like the sounds of the malls in the
1980s they would just put on this light
ambient it would be like they would take
the hits of the day so picture like
whatever the big hits of the 80s were
take all the words out and make it
little more a little more of an
orchestra feeling and that's what I'm
playing in the house all day long every
day now I put it on like basically the
second I wake up and and it's playing
throughout the day um I will post some
music in the in the Ruben report
community and I want you guys to as well
uh Chuck says it seems like too many
things are lining up in favor of
conservatives and this is usually when
the liberal Elites unleash some new and
unexpected chaos what do you think they
are really planning in the darkness well
you know I was thinking with with this
epen thing last night as it was rolling
out and I was really it was it was
rolling out about 900 p.m. and that's
really the time of day like the kids
were already in bed I was sitting on the
couch I was watching Seinfeld as I
usually do and I was just trying to like
not be in the fight for a moment and I
was like H they're putting this thing
out and it's like well what's going to
come after this because anytime there's
anything that points to some evidence of
something it seems like all hell breaks
loose right I don't know I don't know uh
the big thing that people keep saying
right now is we're going to have some
kind of like internet outage that that
that movie on Netflix that I've
referenced a couple times that was
produced by Obama uh Leave the World
Behind that that's what happens in the
movie and that's what people seem to
happen you know is it they roll out
another covid is it that you know the
war in the Middle East expands further
is there an
EMP I don't know I don't know what I
don't know but I think the best thing
you can do is have a little extra food
in your house maybe have a gun you
should have a gun um you know grow some
food if you can if you can build a
garden like do some stuff to take care
of yourself so that whatever the thing
might be um you have a little bit of
extra time and sense about you to to
take care of yourself and take care of
your family who knows like what other
because it's not the thing is it's never
the things we think it's going to be
right like it's never just like oh you
know they're in two weeks they're going
to do this and then that thing happens
it's always something else it's always
some other weird thing so we shall see
uh Dave says congrats on two years in
Florida uh I left California for South
Carolina 3 years ago while we miss a few
restaurants and many friends it was the
smartest thing we have done what other
than the homeless guy throwing poo at
you do you and David Miss have I talked
about the homeless guy who used to throw
poo at us that was remember that guy on
the corner of Ventura and uh right
outside the mall over there um I I don't
miss anything from uh from La we've
discussed this do you guys miss anything
there was this place boa steakhous that
was my favorite like joint to go to at
night and I I went there a couple weeks
ago when we were back in La um I don't
miss anything I don't miss the people I
I don't miss the weather yeah we had
some friends there I had a great house
we had a good life there but I just I
love it here I like being part of
something that you can that that feels
like it's solid and that we can just
continue building goodness with I like
being in a place that everyone that I
talk to that doesn't live here is
thinking about moving here literally
every conversation I have no matter you
know and even our families that were
visiting over Christmas it's like
everybody's like yeah there's something
there's something going on here it feels
like there's Law and Order not not just
feels like there's Law and Order here
there is Law and Order actually like
three weeks ago middle of the night
Clyde's barking his brains out like
going crazy so I walked to the to the
front of the house and I'm looking
through the window and our gate was was
wide open like somehow the gate tripped
and I see a car right there and I was
like oh who is that and it turned
out it was the police because they
noticed that the gate was open and they
were coming by to make sure everything's
okay like like think how fundamentally
different that is than what happens in
say Los Angeles where they can break
into your house and then you get
arrested for defending yourself here my
gate is open the police are just happen
to be driving around making sure
everything's okay so um I is there
anything you were born and bred there
you must miss something hate it that's
what he said come on you had three good
years there we gave you a couple good
years Dodger games Dodger games you
never lived in La only been once you've
only been
once Joey Joey you ever been to La one
time do you do you do you enjoy it
didn't enjoy it all right sorry what can
I tell you Kelly says I don't trust the
government but I have some straightup
conspiracy tinfoil hat wearing friends I
worry that they make other people think
we're all nuts how do you handle them
when they're mostly correct but a little
over the top I don't want them turning
their independent friends and family
away from Republicans you know this is a
great question and it's a tough answer
right right because the sensemaking
layer right when we did the comeback
show uh in the new year on Tuesday what
did I kept saying like we've we've just
blown apart the sensemaking layer we
need a trusted group of people in a
society that are sort of they don't have
to be completely apolitical but they
have to be like you know you you need
them to be like authors and thinkers and
maybe comedians people that are just not
fully ingrained in the system that can
look at it a little bit from the outside
and help make sense of it we used to
have a lot of that we don't anymore one
of the reasons I'm always railing on the
late night uh comedians is because
they've all become partisan hacks as
opposed to you could look at a guy like
Johnny Carson Johnny Carson one night
would have Carl Sean on talking about
science then the next night he would
have Ronald Reagan on and the next night
he would have Bill Clinton on like there
was a wide array of things that you
could talk about and think about and
dissect and then and then a society
could it would leave you to make some
decisions for yourself and we don't have
that anymore you used to turn on CNN and
think you were getting something true
you used to watch ABC or NBC or CBS and
as I've said it just depended whether
you lik Tom broka or you liked Peter
Jennings or the other guy and it's like
there was at least a sense that we all
kind of believe the same things now
we're all off in all of these roads and
these different Avenues and it's like
you can't blame anybody like when I meet
people we had dinner with a friend of
mine in in New York not too long ago he
might be watching this show right now
and he was going on and on and on about
how we've never been to the moon and he
was talking about this filament that
exists above they kept saying filament
and it exists above and we can't break
through that filament something and just
going on and on and on about this stuff
and he and we were having a great time
talking about it and all the
conspiracies and everything else but
it's like I can't blame people that are
conspiracy theorists now because truth
seems to be a time relase pill and we're
finding out that an awful lot of stuff
that we did believe is not true and we
we're finding out that the experts have
lied to us about so much so I don't know
what you do other other than uh plead
your case as best as you can to to keep
people kind of approximately on Earth
Eurasian says if a video of claudian gay
stealing a car had surfaced do you think
that idiot at CNN would have said no no
that's not car theft that's just
borrowing a vehicle without proper
permission now what that now what that
white lady did over there that was Grand
Theft Auto so for those of you that
missed the show yesterday we played this
incredible can we pull that video up
possibly the the video of the CNN guy
from yesterday the guy pretending that
Claudine gay didn't steal she just what
was it she copied and pasted all right
we're gonna we're going to try to grab
that it was just an extraordinary video
you know this whole story breaks
claudian gay president of Harvard or now
resigned president of Harvard there are
over 50 instances of of plagiarism
meaning she actually copied people's
words and did not credit them you would
be kicked out as a student of Harvard uh
if you did that she has now resigned
because of this and and I fully believe
she resigned because of this not the
anti-Semitism thing because they were
going to let her skate by on that this
is what got her anyway check we have the
video so this is yes this is just two or
three days ago on CNN and listen to the
way this guy runs cover it's sort of
like what we just showed you the
headline from The New York Times There's
No Smoking Gun in the Epstein thing oh
Bill Clinton likes young girls watch the
way they run cover for these people
these plagiarism allegations uh where
claudian gay has had to issue
Corrections um multiple Corrections now
we should note that um claudon gay has
not been accused of stealing anyone's
ideas in any of her writings uh she's
been accused of sort of more like
copying uh other people's writings
without attribution so it's been more
sloppy attribution than stealing
anyone's ideas but nonetheless you you
put all of that together just incredible
like it really is just incredible not
Inu not accused of stealing anyone's
ideas just copying without accreditation
just not saying that she sto it's this
exact same thing so yes this is what
these people do and then you wonder why
we don't trust CNN right it gets us to
the earlier question you wonder why you
don't trust the the experts anymore the
experts who lied to you about masks and
injections and all of those things and
over time that is not good for a society
when the entire expert class or the the
entire sensemaking layer when that's
been blown apart and then everybody has
to go all right who do you trust well I
trust Dave Rubin I trust Joe Rogan I
trust this one that one like all right
but none of us are perfect and we're not
experts in all these things and we're
all just trying to slog through it just
like you are James says who is worse
Sunny host or Joy Reed well I've
discussed Sunny earlier on the show I
mean sunny sunny is is genuinely like I
don't give her the good intentions thing
like I I really believe she is a racist
she is a Marxist she she hates America
and all that stuff Joy Reed what has
happened to Joy Reed we don't we don't
talk about Joy Reed that much on the
show anymore I I don't know what's
happened to her like you know she's
she's an idiot she's definitely a
diversity hire um she got I think she
said she got into Harvard because of
affirmative action um I would say in
that Sunny seems more relevant to me
right now she's probably the worst one
uh Samantha says Dear Dave I'm a huge
fan of yours from Portugal and even
though I can't vote in the US elections
I support Ronda santz for president do
you think he still has a chance to win
the nomination well look I think it all
boils down to Iowa it's as simple as
that we have a we have a wacky primary
system the Iowa caucus is uh January
15th so you know less than two weeks
away he has been to all 99 counties
there it sounds like they have signed up
a a tremendous amount of captains these
are the people at the caucuses who rank
angle everybody in cuz this is not just
like a normal one person one vote thing
that get these people to show up in the
caucuses we're all going to vote for
this person blah blah blah if he does
well there I think it I think what it
would do basically is blow up the the
notion that Trump isn't is inevitable
right that he has a force field around
him and can't be stopped and then you
got about four or five days before New
Hampshire and then South Carolina and
then people might go oh well Trump
didn't debate and we thought he was up
but Dan santis won this thing like and I
do kind of like des santis and I wasn't
going to vote for him because I thought
Trump was automatically going to win
like I think there's some chance in
there I understand that I'm outside of
conventional wisdom on that one like
most people think Trump's going to win
this thing in a landslide we shall see
the other thing that I'm seeing out of
mainstream right now is that somehow
Nikki is really hot I I don't really see
that amongst people I see it amongst the
media I don't see it amongst people you
just never know in these elections so
yes I would say he has a chance but if
he doesn't do well in Iowa I don't see
how they reverse that so I think it's
it's Iowa or bust uh lorelli says I have
purchased my ticket to see Jordan in
Salt Lake City on March 5th will you be
there to open for him so you know Jordan
Jordan's going back out on tour for like
five months starting at the end of this
month I am not opening for him on the
tour just I I have too much going on
with the show and and life and
everything else maybe I'll join him for
for some of the stops we're we're
starting to talk about something so
we'll see about that um but I will tell
you that the the two or three shows that
we did we did I did a standup
show uh in Salt Lake City at Wise
Crackers I think which was one of the
best shows that I've ever done Jordan
was my special guest at the end of that
and it was just absolutely a blast and
then we did a show uh the next night the
Jordan show a couple thousand people was
just great and I just love the people of
Salt Lake City I Mormons I think just
have a great sense of humor and are fun
and they can laugh at themselves and of
other people and they're not politically
correct and I yeah I just had a great
time and Salt Lake City is a beautiful
city uh I know Utah's got a couple
problems right now and maybe one of your
Senators ain't so great um but one of
them is pretty great Mike Lee um so yeah
I maybe who knows possibly uh Jen says
what was your reaction oh I see we have
a spoiler note here uh what was your
reaction when you first saw the Golden
Girl series finale it was so fitting
that Dorothy got married can I see that
spoiler alert again just to make sure uh
directors notes spoiler for the Golden
Girl season all right so you haven't
seen the Golden Girl season finale thank
you Connor for doing that uh it did come
out in May of 1992 so this is a hell of
a spoiler alert we're giving to you guys
but in the final two-part episode one
flew from the Cuckoo's Nest darthy
played by bar Arthur obviously Mary's
blanch r mclanahan's uncle played Uncle
Lucas played by Leslie neelen who is the
really the greatest and then they get
married in the second episode and
there's Leslie neelson of course from
from Naked Gun and from airplane
probably the greatest comic actor of all
time and I AB I adored all the ladies
but especially beur so it was just for
me I love the show I remember I was so
sad that night that it was all over I
was 16 years old but like I just loveed
that show so much I still I still watch
it if you watch that show you know one
of the marks of a good show is that it
gets better over time you know a lot of
shows what shows what happens is they're
good for a while and then they jump the
shark and of course jump the shark is
the phrase that happened from Happy Days
where The Fawns in like season seven or
something he literally rides his
motorcycle over a pit with a shark in it
and everyone that's how the phrase jump
the shark um came into the Lexicon
because it was like this is so stupid
the show just jumped the shark so they
refer to other shows where when they
just get get on the other side of being
good uh but a few sit comes that doesn't
happen to and I would say Golden Girls
was as good in season 7 the last season
as it it was better I would say than it
was even in the first couple Seasons um
that was a good spoil I won't tell you
what happens in the last final few
moments but just beautiful uh Amy Says
have you tried Pash ano tequila I bought
some from my husband for Christmas and
he loves it I haven't that's p a TS C I
will check that out for sure uh but I
did get a tequila from a friend of mine
uh that's the bottle that I got I mean
look at that that is a really really
cool bottle this I I have a feeling this
is a pretty penny I didn't buy it for
myself but this is chakira Jaguar head I
think it's extra in AO if I'm not
mistaken I've only had one little uh sip
of it so far but really smooth and
beautiful and the bottle's just really
cool so uh there's always good Tequilas
and our tequila I think I will be going
to Mexico for two days uh in February
for a little tequila tasting because we
are working on the the Dave ruin
official tequila Lynn says I'm starting
to hear that the moon landing was a hoax
oh this could be this could be my friend
Bob with the filament what are your
feelings on it I have a hard time
believing it because they were sending
so many astronauts up in space at the
time I remember watching it with my
friends and it looked pretty real to me
well first of Brock's freaking out over
there what you think it's a hoax I I
think the first moon landing was fake
Brock believes that the first moon
landing was fake um do I believe that
the moon landing was fake I would need
evidence to prove that extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence I
suppose you might say that we would need
more extraordinary evidence to think
that we got there in the first place I
mean what's weird to me is that we have
not been on the moon do you know when
the last time we were on the moon no I
think it was 73 if I'm not mistaken can
someone Google that Google that we have
not been on the moon well we're going to
fact check me here I think since 1973
now if you think about the power of
computing that is in this thing that we
all have in our pocket versus the power
of the computers2 72 okay close enough
versus the power of computers that we
had back then like you may say well
there's no reason for us to go to the
Moon we didn't find any life there
there's no water there there's no
organic material we're off to other
planets now we're working on Mars and
everything else but you'd think that we
we could still maybe have set up shop
there or we could just get back there
real quick or have little trips to go
there or something I mean I know NASA is
not really good at much anymore we used
to send the best and the brightest
wanted to be part of NASA now they want
to be part of SpaceX and work in the
private sector for Elon obviously rather
than than work for the government um I
would say at this point I believe it is
real would it shock me if in a year from
now the the files come out and they made
up that
too I suppose not I suppose not uh a
tennis says can you share more about
your experience using the Big Green Egg
what are your favorite dishes to prepare
with it how does the meat taste
differently from a traditional charcoal
or gas grill so the Big Green Egg is a
smoker we should have snagged a picture
of it or of something I've cooked uh
it's a smoker so it's not a gas grill or
a charcoal grill a charcoal grills or a
gas grill you're just cooking off direct
heat right you're Char broiling you're
getting direct flame on there you can
cook cook indirectly obviously and then
sear after on the on the part with the
fire but you're cooking via fire right a
smoker you're literally cooking via
smoke so you're putting in wood chips
and charcoal that are going to release
the the scent and the Aromas of smoke
and then you cook indirectly so when you
when you have the Big Green Egg or I
think probably any smoker you have
basically a ceramic plate that stops the
fire so the fire is burning but it's not
hitting the meat irly it's just
releasing that smoke and then what you
do with the Big Green Egg which is why
it's fun is you have this uh you have a
sort of nozzle on the top and below a
kind of dial up below and you're
constantly tweaking getting it so that
you're getting that perfect air flow
that perfect temperature that you want
and you're just slowly slowly smoke uh
cooking with smoke so the smoke is is
basically being
injected uh into the meat so basically
you want to cook things that it's going
to take a longer time to cook so brisket
which which is really tough right that's
why they cook brisket for 10 12 14 16
hours brisket I've done where I've done
it I've done it overnight where I put it
in at at 10 p.m. and we don't take it
out till noon the next day you like a
16lb brisket um you can cook more tender
things you could do a filet Manan in
there um but you're only going to have
it in there for like 45 minutes if that
much so it's not going to be quite as
Smoky but if you like barbecuing if you
like being outdoors and cooking and if
you like like if you like meat in
general just like any of that appeals to
you and I love just messing with
seasonings and trying different things
and I'll try to cook a couple different
things on there at once like a te- bone
which I think is a New York strip and a
filet on you know on the same cut of
meat and then I'll also have maybe a
tomahawk in there and you have to time
everything probably like if you if you
enjoy any of that then then I just
highly highly highly recommend that Big
Green Egg uh Arthur says you frequently
say that you will not hire anyone with a
college degree these days does that
include people with degrees from
institutions like Hillsdale College well
look Hillsdale is obviously doing a
great job there are there are a few
colleges that have not gone woke the new
school here in Florida is turning it all
around right now I say it more as it's
not a joke because I do mean it but I
would say I wouldn't absolutely hold it
against someone if they went to college
and they were absolutely the right
person let's put it that way but I have
no it does not impress me that you went
to college right I'm I got two College
dropouts right here in this room right
now like it just it's doesn't that's it
was part of a system that that that
seemingly worked for a long time that
now we know doesn't work and and kids
are going into these schools and they
are coming out with not only a terrible
set of ideas but often racist genuinely
racist ideas they've been taught what to
think not how to think like it's just
it's just not good and the idea even for
my kids that maybe one day they they're
you know they're wrapping up high school
we're trying to figure out what they
want to do and we could be like well you
know we saved some money and what do
maybe you want to travel for a little
bit and then oh you're thinking about
doing this we could put a little money
towards I don't know getting you an
apartment there so that you could go
build that business or you need a little
money to to fund this project that you
want to work on like that seems so much
more appealing to me than being like go
go get your degree in lesbian bad mitt
and let's see what happened you'll
become a Hamas member and then we'll
talk like I'm just not that interested
in that so no I don't think I would have
it as a hard and fast rule um but I just
see no need for it guys people of the
internet is live at 1 pm. with me and
Isabelle Brown uh we've got a postgame
show for a couple more questions at
Ruben report. locals.com in about 37
seconds and uh we have a new Twitter
account it's Ruben report show where
Clips get up there we leave you with a
cold close of it's just been a bad day
for Bill Clinton uh and the Clinton
family and Foundation makes me wonder
how Hillary's going to have him killed
we'll find out stay tuned see you
tomorrow
maybe I'm in danger
[Music]
here